大家好,
我是Jim,
這裡是AI Notebook,
這一集我們看巴黎AI Engineer大會的開幕夜,
三個人輪流上臺,
一個講經濟史,
一個講工程師手上的工具,
一個講一家做模型的公司,
三場聽起來各講各的,
其實在回答同一個問題,
模型進步得這麼快,
為什麼它真正改變我們工作的速度,
卻慢了這麼多,
你現在看到的這張圖是第一位講者放上臺的一條拉得很長,
卻幾乎不轉彎的線,
我們就從這條線開始,
你現在看到的這張圖,
橫軸是年份,
縱軸是美國每個人平均的收入,
他用的是對數座標
意思是每往上一格
就是多乘一倍
所以一路穩定成長
會畫成一條直線
這條線
從19世紀末
一路畫到今天
幾乎沒有轉彎
可是你想一下
這段時間發生了什麼
汽車 飛機 電視 網路
全都是在這條線上
被髮明出來的
這麼多改變世界的東西
加起來
換來的只是每年
文文往上一小步
講者Clemens
把這張圖放在臺上
是想問一件事
AI會讓這條線
變得不一樣嗎
經濟學家的估計
差得非常遠
有人覺得他只會在這條線上
多加一點點
有人覺得他會讓這條線
明顯變陡
Clemens沒有選邊
他想先回頭看看
過去那些真正的大發明
到底花了多久
才讓這條線動起來
Clemens是Lamfuse的
共同創辦人
Lamfuse做的
是幫工程師看清楚
AI應用在做什麼的工具
可是他在學校唸的是經濟史
所以他這樣不講產品
講歷史
他先丟出一個名詞
叫通用技術
英文是General Purpose Technology
縮寫剛好也是GPT
通用技術的意思
是一種會改變整個經濟的技術
它要符合三個條件
它到處都用得到
不是隻有一個產業在用
它會一直被改良
越來越便宜好用
它還會帶動周邊的東西一起長出來
符合這三個條件的並不多
水車 蒸汽機 鐵路 電力 電腦
大概就是這一排
Clements的看法是
AI很可能就是這一排的下一個
所以要猜AI接下來會怎麼走
最好的教材
就是前面這幾個是怎麼走過來的
第一個例子是蒸汽機
最早能用的蒸汽機
是18世紀出一個叫Newcom的人做出來的
主要拿來抽礦坑裡的水
後來Watt把它大幅改良
變得更省眉
也更好用
照理說故事到這裡就該起飛了
可是經濟學家回頭去算
蒸汽機真正把整個國家的生產力推上去
要等到1830年代以後
從發明算起
超過100年
這100年在等什麼
機器本身要先變便宜
要有能做精密零件的工具機
要有鐵路把煤火貨送出去
還要有一整代
懂得操作和修理機器的工人
Clemens在演講最後
用一句話總結這種落差
他說技術有兩個時鐘
一個是發明的時鐘
走得很快
另一個是部署的時鐘
也就是把東西真正用進工作裡走得很慢
這兩個時鐘
也是今晚三場演講共同的主線
電力的故事更清楚
IT正在1880年
在紐約開了一座商用發電廠
可是美國的工廠
很久以後才真的換成用電
到了20世紀初
工廠的動力只有很小一部分來自電力
要再過30年左右才變成大部分
為什麼這麼慢
問題不在電本身
在工廠的格局
蒸汽時代的工廠
是一臺大引擎
帶動一根長長的傳動軸
軸上掛著皮帶
連到每一臺機器
這種做法叫群體驅動
整間工廠要照著那根軸來排
工廠一開始換成電
只是把大引擎換成一顆大馬達
軸跟皮帶都沒動
當然看不出差別
真正的改變
每一臺機器裝上自己的小馬達
這叫單元驅動
從這一刻開始
工廠可以照工作的順序重新排
一臺機器壞了
也不會拖垮整間工廠
CLEMENS的說法是
電力要的不是一顆更好的馬達
是一間重新設計的工廠
電腦也走了一樣的路
到了80年代辦公室裡已經到處都是電腦
可是生產力的數字就是不動
諾貝爾經濟學獎得主Solo
在1987年留下一句很有名的話
說到處都看得到電腦
就是在生產力的統計裡看不到
要等到90年代中後期
數字才終於上來
中間那十幾年
企業在做的事情是改組織
重新設計流程
把供應鏈整個重做一遍
這個現象叫生產力的接續線
它的意思是
一家公司剛導入新技術的時候
要先花錢
先訓練人
先改流程
這段時間生產力看起來反而往下掉
就像借這個字母的底部
等整套東西接好了
曲線才往上翹
你把三個例子排在一起看
蒸汽機要等零件和工人
電力要等工廠重新設計
電腦要等組織改造
每一次
快的都是發明
慢的都是後面那一整套
時間講完了
Clemens接著講錢
每一次大技術出現
資金都會跟著一起衝進來
1840年代的英國
有一段叫鐵路狂熱的時期
鐵路投資最高的時候
大約是整個國家經濟產出的5-7%
後來網路泡沫那幾年
美國攀命舖光鮮
那時候的比例比鐵路低很多
那AI呢
今年蓋資料中心
買晶片
這些AI基礎建設的投資
大約是美國整體經濟的1.8%
你把這三根長條擺在一起
AI已經比當年的光線高
但還沒到鐵路狂熱那種程度
而且預估接下來幾年還會再往上
臺下一定有人想問
這是不是泡沫
Clemens很老實
他說他不知道
也不打算評論
他只提醒大家一件事
就算真的是泡沫
蓋出來的東西並不會跟著消失
鐵路狂熱
後來確實崩了
很多投資人賠得很慘
可是鋪好的鐵軌還在
後來整個國家用很便宜的價格在運貨
網路泡沫也一樣
當年多鋪的光纖
有很大一部分根本沒在用
業界把它叫暗光纖
Dark Fiber
泡沫破掉以後
這些閒置的線路變得很便宜
後來的串流影片和行動網路
才有便宜的基礎可以長出來
Clamens講到這裡
把整場收回來
他說
我們進入深層式AI的時代
大概四年了
快的那個時鐘已經跑得很遠
接下來的問題是
要花多少力氣
才能讓慢的那個時鐘跟上
他給臺下的答案不是更好的模型
是重新設計工作流程
訓練人開新的公司
他最後說
這個房間裡的人
每天在做的就是這件事
而下一位上臺的講者
剛好就是每天都在做這件事的人
第二位上臺的是Kitsy
他做了一個給網頁工程師用的瀏覽器
叫CZ
講話一向很直
他上一次來這個大會
題目叫從Vibe Coding
走到Vibe Engineering
Vibe Coding這個詞
說的是寫程式的時候不太看程式碼
用說的叫AI寫
感覺對了就收下
這次他先帶大家回顧這幾年
一開始
我們拜託ChatGPT把一個函式寫完
還要求他只給乾淨的資料
後來AI可以直接改一個檔案
大家還覺得有點危險
再後來有了Agent
就是會自己規劃自己動手的AI助手
那時候他每做一件事
我們都一項一項按批准
差不多一年之後
他說他認識的人
幾乎全都把權限全開了
資料庫和客戶資料全部交給他
只求他把事情做完
速度確實上來了
可是有一件事
被大家一直丟在了後面
權限一開速度就上來了
問題也跟著來
Kitsy
把現在用AI工作的人分成三種
第一種叫Slob
手榴彈投擲者
Slob是網路上的說法
指AI大量產出
沒有人認真看過的低品質內容
這種人叫Agent
生出一大堆城市碼
自己沒賭
就直接丟給同事
祝你好運
他說臺下大部分的人
包括他自己都丟過
第二種叫肉身代理人
Meet Proxy
老闆交代一個需求
他原封不動貼進AI
AI給什麼
他就原封不動交回去
自己只是中間那根傳聲筒
第三種
才是真正的工程師
這種人其實不多
他還留下一個判斷
他覺得明年會有很多肉身代理人被裁掉
因為中間那一首老闆自己也做得到
這只是他個人的看法
可是他點中了一件事
AI讓產出變得很快
把關的那一段卻沒有人在做
那工程師要怎麼把關
Keys也先看了一圈大家在用的工具
現在能同時指揮好幾個agent的工具很多
這類工具叫編排器
orchestrator
意思是負責分派工作追蹤進度的那一層
他說這三年來
各家的編排器幾乎長得一模一樣
左邊一排聊天記錄
中間是對話
右邊是城市碼改了哪些地方
接著他講到一個更根本的問題
大家嘴上都在說要做軟體工廠
意思是讓AI像生產線一樣
穩定地產出城市
可是一間軟體工廠
到底該長什麼樣子
沒有人講得清楚
每個人的設定都不一樣
你會發現
這跟Clemens講的電力很像
大家拿到了新的動力
卻還在用舊的格局
只是把大引擎換成大馬達
皮帶和傳動軸原封不動
Kitsy這場接下來講的
就是他自己怎麼一步一步
重新排他的工廠
他的第一步
是讓好幾個agent
同時做不同的任務
只要用到一個叫worktree的功能
中文叫工作數
A-GIT是工程師用來記錄程式碼
每次修改的工具
工作數是他的一個功能
能把同一份程式碼分出好幾個工作區
每個agent各改各的
Kiss也本來也覺得這樣很安全
直到有一天
其中一個agent為了測試
要在資料庫裡灌一批假資料
結果碰到的是真的正式資料庫
一口氣把資料全部清空了
還好他有備份
問題出在哪裡
工作數只隔開了程式碼
這臺電腦上的資料庫
密碼 網路
agent一樣摸得到
Kizzie在臺上說
工作室不是沙盒
沙盒sandbox
指的是一個
跟外面完全隔開的環境
裡面怎麼亂來
都碰不到外面的真東西
她學到的是
權限給的越大
agent帶的地方就越要管好
所以她換了一個做法
每一個任務都開一臺
用源就丟的迷你電腦
這種迷你電腦叫虛擬機
意思是在你的電腦裡
用軟體模擬出一臺獨立的小電腦
每一臺小機器裡
有自己的資料庫
有測試用的假資料
還有瀏覽器agent需要的東西都在裡面
可是他拿不到外面正式環境的密碼
任務做完機器就銷毀
下一個任務再開一臺新的
他的電腦一次只能開幾臺更多的任務
就排隊等著
有人把這種小機器叫Orb
Kezy一開始還在網路上嘲笑這個名字
後來自己整套走過一遍
才承認這是比較穩的做法
他在臺上說
我們的角色正在改變
以後我們再替AI當測試員
每臺小機器都會開個網址
你點進去
就能看到他做出來的東西
看過沒問題才收下來
隔離解決了一半
另一半是品質
Agent為了讓畫面上顯示沒有錯誤
會偷偷把檢查規則關掉
這種檢查程式叫Linter
他會自動掃過程式碼
抓出不符合規定的寫法
他打開設定一看
一大堆規則被Agent停用了
他只是想把事情做完
所以他的結論是
規則不能只放在你的腦袋裡
要搬出來放進一個會擋人的檢查器
有些規則
一般的檢查工具寫不出來
他就請Agent幫他另外寫一支
還取名叫警察
最後他秀出自己搭的編排器
任務進來
先寫程式
再審查
再測試
一關一關過了
才會送到他面前給他看
他說
你現在的工作不是寫程式
是在協調一間工廠
這就是Clemens說的
重新設計工廠
Kize把工程師這一側的生產線
從頭排了一次
工程師這一側再重排工廠
那企業那一側呢
第三位講者是
Mistro的工程副總
萊利歐
Mistro是法國的AI公司
自己訓練大型語言模型
成立三年多
他是公司很早期的成員
也是好幾篇Mistral模型論文的作者
他一開場就說
我們不是在追AGI
我們在追有用
AGI是通用人工智慧
指的是什麼事都能做的
跟人一樣好的AI
Mistral選的方向不一樣
他們要的是把AI放進企業裡
把一個個概念驗證
變成正式上線
概念驗證
英文是Proof of Concept
就是先做一個小樣品
證明這件事做得到
企業裡常見的是
小樣品做了一堆
真正上線的很少
用Clemens的話來說
Mistral想做的
就是去推那個慢的時鐘
要推慢的時鐘
光有模型不夠
來利誘藉著講
這一年Mistro買了什麼
第一家是Coyab
一家做雲端運算的公司
他的專場是T城市
開一個隔離的執行環境
也就是剛剛Kids一直在講的沙盒
第二家是Amy AI
來自維也納
做的是用AI模擬物理現象
例如空氣怎麼流過一臺車
你看這兩筆收購
一個補的是agent要住的地方
一個補的是模型
走進工廠要用的專門能力
補的都是部署這一車
然後他放出一張投影片
Mistro
這個月初宣佈原成新一輪募資
金額是31歐元
科技媒體TechCrunch的報道說
這是歐洲科技公司史上最大的一輪股權融資
這筆錢要花在哪裡
他接下來一項一項講
其中一大塊跟資料放在哪裡有關
接著他介紹一個人叫Steven
他在財務部工作
不會寫程式
他想做一個比對數字的小APP給同事用
以前這得找工程師拍時程
現在他在Mistral的產品Vibe裡打一句話
背後就開出好幾個agent
寫程式測試部署
交給他一個能用的APP
整個過程照著Steven自己的權限走
他看不到的資料Agent也看不到
萊利歐說
這套東西背後是一個統一的Harness
Harness原本是馬具
在AI圈指的是
包在模型外面的那一整套工具
權限和流程
讓模型能真正動手做事
同一套Harness
工程師
法務財務都在用
筆電上開始手機上看的結果
這跟Kizi自己搭的工廠是同一種東西
這是Mistro想讓全公司每個人都能用
Agent能做的事越多出事的機會也越大
萊利歐列出了幾個麻煩
Agent的權限通常很大
他每一次的行為不一定一樣
很難寫死一條規則擋住他
他還會被提示注入
提示注入Prompt Injection
指的是有人把指令偷偷藏在Agent會讀到的內容裡
騙他造作
他現場放了一段示範
請Agent去處理程式碼網站GitHub上的一則問題回報
那則回報裡藏了一段指令
Agent讀員真的把一把密鑰貼到了公開的留言裡
所以直接的解法是全部鎖死
可是他說
這樣一來所有的用途也跟著廢了
Mistro的做法是
全現在需要的那一刻才給
只給剛好夠用的量
再加上公司管理員定好的規則
同一段示範開了規則再跑一次
你要在網路那一層就被擋了下來
使用者自己什麼都不用設定
安全之外
萊利歐還講了一個更大的問題
你的資料到底在誰的手上
這件事有一個詞
叫主權
英文是sovereignty
放在AI這裡
它的意思是資料存在哪裡
誰有辦法讀到
模型在哪裡被調整
每次運算在哪裡跑
這些事情
企業自己都要能掌握
不會因為別國的法律
就被別人看光
對歐洲來說這件事特別敏感
Mistro的答案是自己蓋資料中心
他說公司從一家做模型的公司
變成一家做產品的公司
現在又變成自己蓋機房的公司
投影片上是巴黎近郊雷域利的一座資料中心
主要拿來跑推論
推論的意思是
模型訓練好之後
實際回答使用者問題的那一段運算
他說預計今年第三季上線
這座是服務客戶的
跟Mistro另一座訓練模型用的重集
是兩個不同的地方
主權之後
萊利歐最後講的是模型本身
他說更大的通用模型還在路上
今天不發表
他花更多時間講的是專門的模型
他說我們不打算在每一項評比上都盤第一
所謂評比
英文叫benchmark
就是大家拿來比模型分數的標準考題
Mistro做了語音模型
Voxtro也做了讀文件的模型叫OCR
OCR是光學智源辨識
就是把掃描文件和照片裡的字
轉成電腦能處理的文字
7月的新版本
還會標出每個字的位置
和它有多確定
他舉了一個客戶的例子
比例使一家銀行的企業開戶流程要省一大疊文件
以前大部分送來的案子都缺東缺西
換成兩個agent先幫忙檢查以後
缺件的比例降到只剩一小部分
這是單一客戶自己的說法
沒有公開數據可以對照
但他讓你看到
Mistral說的有用長什麼樣子
我們把三長放回同一張圖上
Clemens在最後其實給了一個對照
生技機慢
是因為核心技術本身還要再改良
電力慢
是因為工廠要重新設計
電腦慢
是因為整個組織要改
另外兩位講者
剛好各自佔盡了其中一個
KISSY在做的
是工程師這一車的重新設計工廠
工作室換成用人就丟了小機器
腦袋裡的規則換成會擋人的檢查器
一個人管好幾條生產線
MISTRO在做的
是企業這一車的改組織
一套Harness
不會寫程式的人
也能叫agent做事
外面包一層安全和主權
讓公司敢用
至於核心技術
也就是模型本身
三個人都沒有把它當成最主要的問題
快的那個時鐘已經走得夠遠了
今晚臺上的人
都在想辦法讓慢的那個時鐘走快一點
而歷史告訴我們
這一段從來不會自己發生
我們回到開場那個問題
模型進步的這麼快
為什麼真正改變工作的速度
慢了這麼多
Clemens用兩個時鐘回答
發明走得快
部署走得慢
慢的那一段
要靠整套工作方式重新設計
Kitsy和Mistro
各自拿出了自己的設計圖
最後問一個問題
在你的公司裡
AI現在卡在哪一個時鐘
是模型還不夠好
還是大家做事的方式還沒改
留言告訴我
喜歡的話訂閱AI Notebook
開啟通知
我們下次見